[Music]
you're going to do an exercise called if
I were by Minister via can you stop
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
everyone is welcome
regardless of nationality and if I was
Prime Minister that's what it's done we
have breaking news a large explosion has
gone off in the center city we will
suspend activities until we get some
more information
okay I'm a muscle of PD you heard about
the bomb in the city yes I've been sent
to secure the island
actually can I see your ID yeah sure was
that something went badly wrong and we
need to find out what it's the only way
we will get through this I want to make
him see what is it done
I just wanna beat him maybe this is your
chance the person they're interested he
asked for me why there are witnesses I
need to cross-examine Norway isn't on
trial you are are you sure about that
I just don't want every week not in
front of him
you can be weak and still strong you
know that right I still have hope
trees
in France and it's used to live
[Music]